a big change has been announced to the
final presidential debate which is
scheduled for this thursday
it's all part of an effort to keep it
more civil than it was the last time
ed o'keefe is really on top of this
story for us so ed good morning to you
very curious to hear the big change
hey gail good morning look this is an
interesting change some are going to
like
others will not unlike last time when a
candidate is answering his question for
his allot in two minutes
the other candidate's microphone will be
turned off it's a risky change to what
essentially amounts
to the last potential turning point in
this campaign with tens of millions
potentially watching about 73 million
tuned into the first debate the
president knows this and he told
reporters on his way back here to
washington last night
that he will be at the debate but he
called the rules change quote
very unfair because you didn't think i
should have closed
our country after a contentious first
meeting that led to more than 70
interruptions by the president
the question is radical left will you
shut up listen who is on your list joe
the nonpartisan commission on
presidential debates
is making a change under new rules
announced late monday president trump
and joe biden will each get
two minutes to respond to questions
posed by the moderator
during those two minutes the only person
whose microphone will be on
is the candidate who has the floor both
microphones will turn on again
during an open discussion period and
that
should help avoid moments like this he
still refuses to even say anything to
putin about
the bounty on the heads of american
soldiers your son got injured no no
million dollars
and by the way mr price wait a minute mr
president
your campaign agreed to both sides would
get two
minute answers uninterrupted well your
your side agreed to it
the commission said it discussed the
changes with trump and biden campaign
aides and that it believes the actions
strike the right balance and that
they're in the interest of the american
people
for whom these debates are held the
trump campaign had already raised
objections earlier monday about the
debate
scheduled to be held at belmont
university in nashville
last friday the moderator said that the
debate will cover a range of subjects
including foreign policy but also
climate change
leadership race in america and the
pandemic
in a letter trump campaign manager bill
stephen asked debate organizers to
recalibrate the debate
to only a discussion on foreign policy
claiming it had been led to believe
that would be the only focus in a
statement the biden campaign said
the president is afraid to face more
questions about his disastrous coveted
response
and is more concerned with the rules of
a debate than he is getting a nation in
crisis
the help it needs remember this was
supposed to be the third presidential
debate the second was cancelled after
the president refused to appear
virtually after his covet
diagnosis and we should reiterate the
new rules only cut off a microphone
while the other candidate is answering
his two-minute question
if anything guys perhaps it will force a
little more listening
i know ed let's talk about that for a
second because it does seem like a fair
compromise
you get a full two minutes uninterrupted
and then you get the chance to engage if
you think your opponent is saying
something
that you think is absolutely cuckoo for
coco puffs
so other than what you're hearing from
the president trump's camp
what's been the reaction so far i mean
look this was the reaction a lot of
people had after the first debate why
not
implement a mute button of some kind or
some kind of penalty
uh towards either of them if they
interrupt biden interrupted the
president as well just not as often
so you know clearly the trump campaign
made their objections known the binding
campaign says they'll be there
and uh we'll see how it goes okay well
now you know when you're going to be on
mew
now you know say a prayer for the audio
guy yes indeed
that's right they may be very busy that
night
how many more days that i miss your
little wife 14 more days two weeks from
today we will be ready
thank you ed o'keefe two weeks on the
nose